this is something I I do feel very
strongly about
um The Last of Us
did you guys watch the latest episode
lesbo love don't hit like gay love bro I
need that for real the lesbo love don't
hit the same right yeah it didn't hit as
hard for sure I was gay during that
episode three yeah like I'm looking at
my wife like will we ever have this that
happiness will we ever be this in love
with one another but the lesbo love yeah
I was not buying it well I'm glad
because they're like high school age so
I'm glad you weren't real yeah maybe you
just don't like kids romantically being
Affiliated huh that's a very good way to
spin this yeah trying to say I'm not a
pedophile
yeah I think because it was weird
they're both great actresses I love that
girl in the in Euphoria yeah
sister in Euphoria yeah and I love the
girl that plays Ellie yeah she's
unbelievable and they have good
chemistry and they had good chemistry
yeah but it was like
uh
you just see it too much I need butt
[__] I think I need it I think I need
like dope when it was chest to chest
with the dues and the hairs and the
hairs yeah Tangled and [__] it's more
visceral you know yeah yeah lesbian
lovers just like oh you see that that's
cute two girls kissing it's like yeah
you're trying to get my attention
two guys kissing Oh you mean it yeah
yeah yeah you're way more committed when
you go gay as a man the gay as a woman
gay as a woman
yeah
well no that's a tattoo yeah
bro I've been playing the game last of
us I don't want the second one [__] I I
started playing the second one yeah no
Sun control
for about a week bro it's not
self-control okay here's the thing I
don't want to give away too much but
like you got to play as girls in the
second one right you got to play these
two not only just girls like day in love
like lesbian girls the ones from
I'm not going to say who's it who it is
but like nobody's straight on this show
I think yeah but nobody I'm playing this
game but the game is so fire this has
got to be what it was like like being
white when black people started playing
sports uh but like for your team yeah
no what is it is about the first the
head coach who has an integrated team
and he's like really against it and then
as the team keeps winning with the black
people they're like dude these guys are
the best oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah so it's just so
you you going through the emotion where
you're just like where you're like Ugh
they're putting together this [__]
story and jamming everything into this I
mean they managed to jam Holocaust into
the [__] Last of Us story you like
random in in part two you like randomly
go to like uh what is it called the
Jewish temple
and like one of the girls is Jewish and
she's like oh I remember this place and
he goes oh you know just this reminds me
of like what my people have been through
you know and then and then the girl
Ellie is just like well what do you mean
like you know and then she's like well
what do you mean I mean the Inquisition
the Holocaust and now this fungus it's
like we're constantly just moving and
being eradicated I'm like what is
happening right now the fungus would
kill the Jews the fastest though you
have to be honest I don't know I okay
this immune system-wise like it's just
like a nightmare in there you know what
I mean like the fungus I think gets them
out of here I know who they will blame
the fungus on
who the Jews they blame everything
that's the first person they're blaming
it on did you somehow actually I don't
know how but it's the Jews Asia
yes I mean it literally came out of what
the Vietnam to think that a pandemic
started in Asia in a lab how racist yeah
that is
not bad my bad yeah anyway I don't want
to tell you guys too much about that
other thing but um that is a little bit
how I felt initially with this episode
where it was like I felt like they were
they already had a gay storyline and now
I felt like we were revisiting a similar
thing where you're like getting us used
to something that's we're normalizing
something we're not used to and like
that was kind of what was powerful the
first time with the dudes yeah and now
it's like yeah but we've been there
yeah I would rather have seen like oh
this is teenage female friendship in a
way that's fun and you don't often see
depicted on TV yeah normally it's guys
hanging out [__] on each other or
whatever you don't often see the female
point of view of that which is like
these girls were teasing each other
having fun whatever and then I thought
actually the Love Story took away from
that a little bit and she killed shorty
huh
I think is how it goes yeah because she
alludes to it yeah remember which is
earlier episode she's like I've done it
once before yeah is that your first time
killing someone she's like no I've done
it once before I think she has to kill
her best friend yeah but you play the
game so you know what happens I mean I
don't wanna I don't wanna I feel like
you are just ruined it but I don't want
to ruin it for you I feel you just did
ruin it I mean I do want to ruin it
actually I think you already ruined it
you just said she kills who kills who
someone no I'm saying oh yeah
you get like a good five minutes in
every time
I did that too it's all good grief be
honest you did that in school they'd be
like who wants to discuss the book and
you didn't read the book but you just
kind of go for it no you over did that
no you pray to God they don't call on
you
you always answer first and then you
everyone knows the basic parts
oh no you read Wuthering Heights play
more
it's been making your thoughts what'd
you think of the actual episode besides
the gay thing didn't hit as hard I
thought it was I mean the episode
they're great they're [__] brilliant
everything works I think what I'm more
curious about is you know let's progress
this storyline yeah I mean because you
have to understand they stopped the
episode and we don't know if my man
Joel's gonna be okay or not yeah and I
care more about Joel being okay than I
care about their lesbian love I think
you get the sign he's gonna be okay when
she starts stitching him up that's like
okay she saved him but we gotta wait the
whole up for that an hour exactly and he
was dying at the last hour exactly so
you took a whole hour I just thought it
was almost like a filler episode she'll
brought up a great point he was like yo
if you want to tell the story great but
like show us what fedra's doing that's
so [__] up there's this entire world
you're not really showing us like what's
actually happening that the fireflies
feel like they need to have an uprising
or yeah what is Federer doing they were
clearing out communities who were they
killing who are they whatever I think
there's so much more to explore there I
think it's like um they're using fedra
as like the perfect example of
government overreach yes in an extreme
time yes right and like you know some
people look at what happened with the
pandemic and they'll be like well you
see what happened was there when there's
a pandemic the government steps up and
says hey you got to stay inside you
can't go outside you can't work you
can't provide for yourself this is the
extreme version of that so whereas fedra
is probably thinking Hey listen we're
keeping these people safe without us
they're just a bunch of animals out
there killing each other yeah there's
one thing that we have to do is you know
enforce some rules and it sucks that we
got to take out some people we're
holding Society together yeah which is
what government always thinks and they
felt during the pandemic but I agree the
game doesn't really show that either you
just gotta kind of like take it
yeah take a face value that they are an
abusive governmental system that was put
in place right after this you know yeah
I just wish we didn't have to fill in
those gaps ourselves and the show will
diverse from the game because it doesn't
seem that bad in the show no you're like
all right sounds pretty good yeah even
sewage Duty it's like people do that and
that's a real job [__] like
there are people that clean out the
suits fair enough right like it's not
like this is a new job
also wait let's do let's do yeah it's a
good point it's a fraction of the
doo-doo it's a good point like the girl
said I'm gonna join a terrorist
organization so I don't clean up [__]
you spoiled little [__]
right like like she got relegated to do
Duty and then she was like I gotta kill
people yeah she would rather murder
soldiers than clean up [__] that's
spoiled bro I think I'm going that route
too bro you think yeah I want to deal
with [__] I'm not trying to ruin his
fits yo yeah yeah he literally did do
that when he was a nurse he was like I'm
not cleaning up [__] oh my God I used to
flirt with girls in the class and get
them to do it for me this is consistent
wait why would you have to clean it you
have to wipe them afterwards yeah like
uh older patients that are they just
nurses like a doctor's janitor yeah
it pretty much is yeah how thorough
would you wipe I mean I never did never
wiped
away come on I swear to God that's cat
bro I swear to God I swear I swear to my
mom I never got in that giggy bro why
would you be a nurse I didn't know that
was part of it
you took that whole test and Plex or
whatever it's called the dumb idiots
did you take them yeah I did damn yeah
what'd you get a house 27. 27 not good
100 30 is like you're you should get in
somewhere if you have 30 everybody's
like that's the one I I think maybe if I
took it one more time I'd have got there
but it's so much [__] so many eight
hours a day of studying or whatever
yeah
I could at least dump Podiatry it would
be a good nurse though
not in an insulting way
no but he's like he you have good
bedside manner like people feel
comfortable and you're concerned about
like what I hear a lot of times about
doctors is that they're not doing a lot
of the caregiving yeah okay so it's like
if you actually are in it for the
caregiving you want to be the nurse
that's true if you want the money The
Prestige and you know obviously if you
want to be maybe a surgeon or something
like that like go for the doctor stuff
but if your passion is the caregiving is
that your passion or I want to help
people but I don't want to clean up [__]
either you know what I mean I don't and
I don't want the lack of prestige of
being an Indian nurse yeah yeah I mean
that's oh no you can't do that that's
like being a white criminal yeah what's
that [__] dick they called the super
nurse
[Music]
but yeah she's gonna be a nurse
practitioner technically by a degree
yeah but what were you saying about it I
was curious
she a nurse
but for me your wife delivers baby she's
a she's a midwife yeah exactly isn't
that what it means nursing practice
nurse practitioners ain't all nurses
Nurse Practitioners
yeah exactly yeah exactly you're a
practitioner of nursing you know yeah
practice nursing you're just practicing
I think that makes sense your wife ain't
a nurse should I look into this I'm just
telling you yeah I might need to call
her and be like hey what the [__] have
you been doing all this time your wife's
a doctor bro oh really yeah if you
deliver the baby yeah is there a doctor
present when she's delivering nope she
doesn't get paid
let me ask you one question me and my
family
check it out what dumbass okay the pilot
on a plane the pilot on the plane dies
idiot okay
okay
the flight attendant yeah starts to fly
the plane now what
that's a step
pilot no yes that's a pilot you'll watch
the doctor my wife is a stepfather [__]
you yeah
until a doctor comes in and delivers
them little Jew babies your wife's a
doctor your wife's a Jew doctor she's
gonna get more money then your wife's a
Jewish doctor
nobody's doing she's not Jewish acting
way more Jewish though clearly she came
over there to sit down and said no I
swear to God
I was like what did you just say she was
like oh I said oh shoot and I said no
you didn't oh [__] that's scary I know
that's scary bro it's been happening
with it with the sticky lingo it's like
how Islam's taking over what
it's like the new cool word oh yeah yeah
the culture wars the culture wars
Islam's winning bro what's the Christian
word Jesus Christ all right y'all had a
good one that's right God damn it God
damn it is good boy God damn you think
they're the first ones to say God damn
it but his English is their God huh
Insha'Allah is God
God willing inshallah they call God
Allah okay God damn it is their God
that's what they call God God yo y'all
one and the fact that we call it God
yeah whoa
[Laughter]
so white people rename God the holy God
but before it used to be different terms
I meant the men Jews called it Hashem
Hashem we say bhagwan they say God God
and now everybody calls it God so even
if you're praying to bug one you're
still saying God though yeah but you
know it's wild oh [__] that's kind of
fun Allah just means god in Spanish
it's God's
hmm
what do you mean
it's plural My Boy
is plural aggressive these Spaniards
look at that hit that g herbo figure it
out
now what [__]
now what you're gonna do so Spaniards
are worshiping all the gods is that what
you're trying to say I think it's the
lasting effects of paganism
infiltrating the Christian religion
vernacular she leaves you have multiple
gods you're pagan
yeah that's a pagan right here you are
pagan according to that
music oh that was a good point actually
boy blah blah we have a word for
everyone Pagan yeah I thought that was
when your girl's straps on [__] your
neck what no oh Peggy thank you guys for
watching that exclusive clip from our
patreon episodes you could join the
[__] Army at patreon.com
flagrant we have a new episode that
comes out every single Friday plus all
of our back catalog episodes go join
right now peace